[Music]
i was very sorry to hear that you were
injured recently at work thank you yes
that was my exciting uh thing that
happened this year i got a big uh gash
on my leg at work and how did that
happen you guys not taking precautions
well i'd like to blame someone uh but my
husband's the boss so i just
you know right it's uh we were shooting
in this old abandoned warehouse we were
our characters are obsessed with lethal
weapon so this year we make lethal
weapon six
and um
i was it was a scene between rob my
husband and myself and i was playing a
cop and he was playing murtaugh who in
the in the lethal weapon movies played
by danny glover okay and um so he's
playing the danny glover role you're
playing a cop and you're in a warehouse
i'm a cop yeah it's this old shady not
very safe looking place and i come
running in i'm supposed to stop and our
first take i stop and my leg just goes
through something and i'm on the ground
and it was this metal grate that like
went in my lid it was it was really bad
and it just kind of it sliced it right
open so it was a 9-1-1 situation so
ambulance uh the the emts show up they
did they showed up and they were like
okay what's the issue i said there's a
giant hole in my leg if you want to take
a look at it i don't want to look again
and they were like okay well is there
anything else i was like
no but i mean
that's it they're like right but is
there anything else that was i it's five
inches long and you can see my bone if
you want to look there doesn't need to
be anything else that's all there is
and they're like what's their problem
well he goes what's going on with your
stomach and i looked down and i was
wired with a blood pack to be shot
which went off when i fell so it looked
like i
that's great so you're like i've got
this cut they're looking at my legs a
basketball-sized hole in your stomach
ma'am i'm like that's nothing
don't worry about that i've hurt my leg
i've had that forever this is always
like this that's crazy but then we went
to the uh emergency room and everyone
was staring at us and i'm thinking
yeah i got this isn't real it's just
like a blood pack thing i just was
trying to focus it really was very
painful
but everyone's staring at us and after a
while i realized they're they're not
staring out of concern it's not the
blood they're looking at they're like
glaring at us and finally i looked at
rob and i was like why are they
oh right and then i remembered that my
husband uh had brought a picture but oh
he was he looked a certain way oh my god
[Applause]
[Laughter]
you can explain to everyone no no